now the discussion is that we've had
this the greatest insurrection
since the civil war maybe greater than
the civil war was this january 6th thing
according to these people
so now they have to have a new sort of
patriot act they got to have a new
domestic terrorism you know catch all
that they're going to go after us but
i tell people who think that would be
great i tell them to be careful what you
wish for
because the definition of what they call
an insurrectionist may well be
that you teach your kids at home that
you voted for donald trump or you went
to a trump rally
it could be that you believe in you know
being left alone you believe in the
second amendment somehow you may own a
gun
god forbid that be in california but you
may own a gun
and if so you may well be an
insurrectionist and then they can look
at all your stuff
and see if they can find you or entrap
you into a crime
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an ophthalmologist a senator from the
great state of kentucky
and a man who celebrates festivus every
year
senator rand paul welcome back to the
reuben report
thanks dave thanks for having me i was
hoping you were gonna have your festivus
poll with you
but i guess it's just a seasonal thing
for you if you show up on festivus we
will do some wrestling so uh
you know we'd be prepared all right so
you
are in dc i am in la who's worse off
right now
well we have razor wire that surrounds
our campus now
so the likes of you and any other
american citizen that wants to visit
their capital
you're not welcome here because you got
to call up nancy pelosi she's got to
come out to the fence
to get you to bring you in and so
there's no tourism in dc
there are no government workers and you
want to see some sad people
there's a local restaurant we go to
called the dubliner around the
corner and it's owned by a family
they're wonderful people
they've no customers nobody works
anymore the whole all dc is like a
vacant city
and now we've got razor razor wire
surrounding the capital
so it's really the most uninviting scene
you'll ever see
have you been yeah have you made any
headway figuring out you know i know
they extended it i suppose this
emergency situation quote-unquote
emergency situation for two months or
something
have you made any headway finding out
like what do they really think is going
on
at this point well it's a secret it's
top secret but if i tell you you won't
tell anyone
i no i won't i won we're not even going
to record this thing
yeah it's it's about optics and on
january 6 they weren't prepared for a
big crowd
and in all likelihood that was nancy
pelosi making bad decisions about being
prepared for the crowd
and so what is she doing now she's
overcompensating
so they were under prepared and now
they're over prepared there hasn't been
there's not a protester within 100 miles
of dc
in fact if you come shopping in dc bank
of america will give up your credit card
information to the feds so they can
search your computer
and decide whether or not you're an
insurrectionist or not
so i asked the fbi about this and they
won't respond to us we've asked them in
writing
did they demand these records from bank
of america did bank america just
volunteer to be america's you know spy
you know for your credit card system but
to look at everybody's shopping habits
and decide that then we'll investigate
you if you were shopping on january 6th
in dc
is abhorrent to the idea that the fourth
amendment means anything
how fearful are you that all of the
the ideas that you've cared about for
your whole career the ideas that your
dad put forth the ideas that the
founders put forth about freedom and
liberty and all those things that they
really feel like they're sort of coming
to the
end right now well you know the
democrats have admitted this before you
remember
uh um emanuel saying back when that no
crisis go to waste
this is a crisis once again we had a
crisis of 9 11.
but guess what the patriot act was
written in the 1990s put on a shell
and they waited till they finally got a
disaster a real disaster
but they had 911 they brought it out but
it was about people control and it was
about control of ideology
now the discussion is that we've had
this the greatest
insurrection since the civil war maybe
greater than the civil war was this
january 6th thing according to these
people
so now they have to have a new sort of
patriot act they got to have a new
domestic terrorism you know catch all
that they're going to go after us but
i tell people who think that would be
great i tell them to be careful what you
wish for
because the definition of what they call
an insurrectionist may well be
that you teach your kids at home that
you voted for donald trump or you went
to a trump rally
it could be that you believe in you know
being left alone you believe in the
second amendment somehow you may own a
gun
god forbid that be in california but you
may own a gun and if so
you may well be an insurrectionist and
then they can look at all your stuff
and see if they can find you or entrap
you into a crime
uh this is coming it's become a bizarre
place in dc it's a military camp and
essentially we now have people who have
receded into their own camps
and um i i fear what's coming really
because of
how radical the left wing has become and
they're not willing to take no for an
answer
so it used to be they said well we don't
have 60 votes in the senate so we won't
get everything we want
now they're gonna they're gonna they say
they're gonna hold off on the filibuster
my prediction is within six months
they'll get rid of the filibuster
and by brute force they'll ram through
their entire agenda
which is farther to the left than most
people in america could really imagine
okay so the million-dollar question i'm
with you i think everyone that that is
sensible
is worried about all this stuff do you
think joe biden is in charge of the
democratic party
joe joe who's that who are you talking
joe the guy that gets up there
the figurehead over in the white house
yeah now
i think it's a mixture no do i think
he's actually the president
and in charge yes but what i would say
is that there's a great deal of
influence
coming from the left wing of his party i
don't think he has maybe the
uh fortitude he may have had 15 years
ago to
stick with positions that he might
disagree with the left-wing mob
on so i think that largely policy will
come from the left side
the energy of the democrat party is
coming from the socialist crowd
coming from the woke crowd and so i
think they will dictate most of what
goes on there
um and that's what we're going to see
over time but i don't think you're going
to get a moderate president
it's sort of like the idea of you know
whether or not they could give our kids
you know cross-gender hormones without
our permission that's not a moderate
position
that is a far out extreme position even
if you're a democrat
most democrats if you talk to them would
say that children
really shouldn't be allowed to have
surgical procedures without their
parents permission
they're arguing that even if their
parents say no the government's allowed
to intervene to say yeah so
now this isn't a moderate crowd or a
middle class woke i mean this is really
the world crowd you're going to see yeah
so to that point you
you got into it with rachel levine who
uh
what's the position she was going for is
it deputy health secretary
yeah she'll be the assistant and uh my
question to her was basically that
if a child says they want to take uh
change their sexual appearance
and the parents say no would the
government intervene
to involve themselves and side with the
child
and the answer basically coming from
these people is yes
the other answer that comes from them
kids between the ages of 3 and 10
go to these clinics older kids go too
but 10 of the kids are between the ages
of 3 and 10.
when they get there do you think
anybody's counseling them against this
no everybody there has already undergone
the procedure themselves or is an
activist for this
this uh you know decision and they
there is no counterpoint there so the
kids are given
you know reassurance and told this is a
great thing and you need surgery and you
need these hormones
and if your parents say no we're not
going to tell them you even have schools
that used to not give a kid a tylenol
are willing to give these kind of
powerful hormones
that have life-altering changes to the
body
willing to give these to kids without
telling the parents
that is alarming and i think most
parents who think through this would be
alarmed about this yeah
i agree obviously and and i think most
parents do they just seem to be afraid
to speak up but i know your crunch on
time so let's let's just do four
questions like two or three minutes each
and because
you have a couple of bills coming uh
that i think are really interesting but
first real quick on on the lockdowns
at this point you know i'm still in a
lockdown state and city here california
la
uh what's your position basically at
this point now that states are
slowly opening up i think if you want to
go out and eat you should become better
friends with governor newsom he
apparently
is allowed to go out so and apparently
it's pretty good food oh yeah
french laundry bad dinner some of the
best wine in napa
so uh you just need better friends dave
and you'd go out
or you can come visit another state it
is night and day as you travel the
country
if you go to florida which has a lower
death rate than
california or new york or new jersey
um it's wide open you hardly see anybody
wearing a mask you still have
people freaking out saying i saw a
person at the beach i saw someone at the
beach and they didn't have a mask on
oh my god what's gonna happen but uh
they don't chase down surfers like they
do in california
you know they don't send the coast guard
after someone on a paddle board
um but there really is a difference
between the states
and uh i think that it's getting to the
point though that where the statistics
are so overwhelmingly good
that this disease is leaving us they're
going to be hard-pressed to really make
up
some sort of narrative that we have to
go on but they will you know falchi is
still saying wear a mask into 2022
but if you look at the daily incidence
of disease it's a straight downward line
and i'm thankful for that and i think
it's a combination of both natural
immunity and the vaccine
that's bringing it down um the deaths
are coming down
and you know there was a doctor in the
wall street journal about two weeks ago
from johns hopkins
and he's predicting by the end of april
this could be gone nobody knows for
certain
but i would take his counsel in mind
as much or more than faustia who says oh
there's gonna be another worldwide
you know surge and it's all but over and
we're gonna have to
you know the planet will be
uninhabitable in another 10 years
these doomsday people um really we need
to hear
countervailing opinions that's for sure
senator are you saying that i might be
able to celebrate with my family before
july 4th i might be able to see my
parents before independence day
as long as there's two or three of you
and no more and you have to put it on
zoom so dr fauci can watch your
celebration
and uh make sure you only do the uh what
are the sticks that light up
not don't do anything oh sparklers
sparklers no sparklers
sparklers only yeah sparkles but no
explosive fireworks for you
in a weird sense though as you've seen
the states do such
wildly different procedures does that
prove that federalism kind of does work
i mean i know you don't want
the federal government telling everyone
what to do but as you've seen just
florida do what's right for florida and
then
the people that are stuck in cali are
just stuck in cali like it kind of is
how the system's supposed to work right
well i think the interesting thing is is
you have all these different sets of
data because you had 50 states doing 50
different policies
we also had hundreds of different
governments around the world doing
different policies
and if someone will objectively look at
this we have more data on this disease
than anything we've ever had in the
history of man
but the one thing that is for certain is
the highest death rate for any
governmental unit
is new york and new jersey so they were
probably the most restrictive
you know in towns but they had the
highest death rate
sweden did most leadings voluntarily and
has one of the lower death rates
in the end the death rates all sort of
coalesced and i think in the end the
argument could be made that man had very
little effect on the trajectory of this
until the vaccine and even the vaccine
right now i think it is definitely
helping
but i think that the huge incidence of
disease in december and january
also the natural immunity is a big part
of this disease coming down so it's
natural immunity
plus uh you know the vaccine that's
really doing a trick
i'm getting the question i get in the
hall four times a day now is are you
gonna take the vaccine or you're going
to take the vaccine
and i'm pro-vaccine i'm four people who
are at high risk taking the vaccine
but i tell them look 30 million people
in america have had the disease like
myself
there's maybe a handful and some of
these are questionable there may be a
handful of people got it twice
but guess what there's zero
hospitalizations from anybody getting it
the second time
and zero deaths and so like can we not
just let somebody else have the vaccine
you know i'm perfectly content i've had
it
do you have to harass me every day
saying i need to be vaccinated
because dr fauci wants me to vaccinate
him but realize that's another noble eye
on his part
he only wants to be vaccinated as an
example as a model
he knows it's of no value to me and if
he were in private he would
admit as much but he's once again lying
to us telling that all the people who've
had it you have to take it again
because it's about examples it's about
conformity it's about submission
has nothing to do with science what
would you say to the average
say healthy 44 year old who has not had
it
uh should they be going to get the
vaccine
once it's available you're saying like a
healthy 44 year old or someone like you
yeah well in effect you know someone
yeah
someone like me well just a relatively
healthy
relatively young person for the sake of
argument we'll say that you're both of
those relatively young and relatively
healthy
we'll stipulate to that anyway um i
think you weigh the risk and i don't
want to be too uh
much you know trying to enforce my
opinion on a 44 year old
if you want to make the decision you
base it on the rate of death
for your age group and your body type
versus the the risk of the vaccine so
for example right now if i were in
europe
and you told me i could get the
astrazeneca vaccine
or be 44 year old and healthy i'd stay
the hell away from the astrozenica
vaccine sounds like there's enough
complications there's a lot of cities
cut a lot of countries uh going away
from it
and here's the other question for our
country and people don't want to bring
this up because it has to do with the
truth and you'd have to think through it
i believe the astrazeneca is a
adenovirus
i think johnson johnson is an adenovirus
so i would ask a question before i took
the johnson johnson in our country
how is it different to the astrazeneca
vaccine and how is it
saying because i don't know if we've had
enough people yet are we going to have
the same problem with the johnson and
johnson i'm sure they'll be calling me
after this
i don't know if it's true but i think
it's worth it can somebody at least
ask the question um the other ones the
mrna vaccines
uh moderna and and pfizer now we've had
millions of people take them there are
some complications
but if you're over 80 without question
it's much better take the vaccine than
not if you're over 70
in all likelihood yes with each
successive decade down it becomes more a
more marginal benefit
the other thing that's happening is the
disease is coming down dramatically
right now from both natural immunity and
the vaccine
you know if you're unsure wait a month
and make a decision you know of course
dr fauci will be mad at me for saying
that but
in a free country it's your decision to
make and there isn't an absolute right
or wrong
you know i know for myself i've already
had it i'm not taking it again
um if you tell me like in the next two
months that a lot of people had it start
dying
i'll probably reevaluate i'm not going
to be adamant that i'm not taking it
but right now there's nobody who's died
from a second infection
and i know of nobody who's been
hospitalized from a second infection
so i'm a little cautious with wanting to
get re-vaccinated since i've already
been vaccinated the old-fashioned way
it's just incredible because you're
giving me a much more robust and honest
assessment than anything that that we're
hearing out of fouchy but all right
i just want to talk quickly about two
bills that you've introduced
uh because i'm not a big fan of bills
but every now and again something comes
in to actually restrict
the power of the government over the
people talk to me about the
the reigns act the reigns act says that
when unelected bureaucrats want to write
a regulation
that would injure the economy or cost
the economy over 100 million dollars
that lo and behold they shouldn't be
allowed to do it without congress
approving of that regulation
this is one of the most amazing things
that i learned when i got here is that
most of the onerous costly expensive
regulations are not written by your
legislators
they're written by bureaucrats the
legislators write a
survey or a sort of a shell of a bill
that lets the regulators write all the
teeth of the regulations
like under obamacare there were 1500
references
to the secretary of health shall decide
at a later date so really obamacare was
written by the secretary of health
so same way with these so under the
reins act if it passed
these major regulations would be created
by bureaucrats but sent back to the
house to be voted on
to my mind this is one of the best
reforms that's out there
for trying to restrain big government uh
so far we have let me think
oh zero co-sponsors from the democrat
side
probably 20 or 30 republicans we may
have had one vote in the past and we get
most of the republicans on board and
almost no democrats
uh at one time manchin was a co-sponsor
of this i don't know if he'd vote for it
now but at one time he was a co-sponsor
i don't think we have him on it anymore
but it shows that there really is a
difference between the parties
it doesn't mean all republicans are good
but doesn't mean that no democrats are
any good on regulation
so so when you introduce a bill like
that and you know it's not going to get
any bipartisan support and struggle with
your
within your own party are you doing it
more just because you want people to
understand these ideas i mean you want
people to at least
hear about some of this stuff well
because if it passed this is how we
would fix our government
i think people want to have solutions
the other thing is
is that perhaps somebody running for you
know
senate in arizona decides well it's a
great idea and i'm going to run my
campaign
on this issue that regulations should
have to be approved by congress
i think it's it's something that could
be a motivating force for people in
election cycles
it's the same reason i oppose you know
sending stimuluses to dead people even
though i know everybody appears for it
but i'm not really for sending stimulus
checks even though i'm not going to win
i'm not for sending stimulus checks to
dead people last summer
over a million dead people got stimulus
checks to the tune of over a billion
dollars
so i introduced legislation to fix it it
passed by unanimous consent
but a democrat senator came running to
the floor and said no i object but he
was too late
and so it got passed and then it went to
the house but he was mad because we
passed it over his objection so he got
his buddies in the house to
to stop it and then when they finally
did get around to they said well we're
really
kind of for this we kind of maybe think
but some dead people's relatives could
use this money and
and so they did pass it but they said we
will only end
the process of sending checks to dead
people in three years
so this is how ineffective your
government is they can't even
immediately
end sending checks to dead people it
takes them three years to to unravel the
complexity of
mailing checks to did people i believe
this is what we call the swamp all right
the other the other piece that you're
trying to get past is the national right
to work
act yeah i think that uh you shouldn't
be fired for
the choice whether you join a union or
not it should be up to you
and we shouldn't sort of have federal
legislation that encourages
businesses to fire people who say i just
decided
you know i don't like let's say you're
pro-life and you don't want all the
money going to
uh you know planned parenthood or
something you say i don't want to send
money to my union
because it sends money to the the
democrats for this and so i think that
should be your choice
so this national right to work law
doesn't really add new law you should
like this all it does is take away law
so some of the labor law from the 30s
and 40s mandated
this protectionism for unions and all it
does is strip that away
it's not anti-union in fact i think
there are times
when the smaller players should be
allowed to come together to use their
leverage to strike a better deal
whether it's wages or prices frankly so
i'm for like consumers
forming a union or a co-op to negotiate
with big
big insurance and big tech and everybody
else i think there are ways that we can
get the consumer
to have more leverage so i'm not against
the idea of union
of of collectively trying to go there
for something
but i think you should have a choice how
as as basically
one of the few people that actually
cares about limited government
and all of the principles that i'm
constantly espousing on the show
do you just not go crazy while working
for the government like especially
now as it's gotten so out of control
like truly
how do you just like manage to have a
smile on your face and be funny and
fun and happy in the rest of it while in
the midst of that thing
you know when a golfer gets the shanks
he has to get a sports psychologist
i have a couple of sports psychologists
on the payroll they follow me around
and what we've also decided to do is go
with the science dave and i can't
believe you don't do this
here's what the science tells tell me
please the national science foundation
says
that if you will take a picture a selfie
of yourself smiling
and look at it later in the day you'll
be a happier person and so that's what
the science says dave
and if you will do that and not get on
twitter but look at selfies of yourself
smiling be a much happier person
and don't talk politics either you got
to give up on talking politics
that's the most sensible thing i've
heard anyone in politics say in a long
time senator rand paul i appreciate the
time
all right thanks dave if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell